the most hardcore game made by two manly
men cinnamon toast can I challenge you
for rock paper this so manly
but wait there's the twist whoever loses
gets to control the other person's
computer remotely via advanced
technology for 30 seconds oh my god I
won't lose to you PewDiePie Oh we'll see
about that
[Music]
I'm scared that's such a dumb idea
listen I never seen anyone do this on
YouTube that's how you know it's a bad
[ __ ] idea everyone else is like no ho
[ __ ] away rock paper sis I don't even
know if it's gonna work out we'll just
give it a try we're gonna do rock paper
set you ready I'm ready are you ready
for this are you ready for this no yes I
did it how we get the hack into
PewDiePie's computer start the cool
hacking montage
[Music]
broke in 30 seconds no get out of there
Kent
yeah get out of there finally what are
you gonna do no I don't like my channel
check 30 seconds you're back rematch
beauty all right I'll get you this time
you see I'm sure you will you think
you're in my head I'm in your head oh
[Music]
it's payback time it was really gonna
delete you you [ __ ]
I promise for you we're gonna delete my
channel
let me just connect to your shitty piece
of [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what are you doing in
there no no please God no don't do it
I'm a huge god damnit
oh yeah I got 10 seconds left
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] in it yeah are you
kidding me
that's all I had it goes by so fast
alright I got that ass this time go down
[ __ ] delayed [ __ ] me over
maybe we should give you two the more
time maybe maybe we should give it to
the board Tom um nothing very good yeah
yeah I think we're good
what are you doing in my channel trailer
what do you pay what are you pasting
that's the rock paper scissor legs you
dumb-butt you're blowing blue come Jesus
Christ come on all right you won't pick
the same thing twice right Oh absolute
power I hate this game going back in no
yeah I got to close that crooked it this
time yes okay
[Music]
you got 20 seconds oh god damn didn't
work you got denied watch this video
they do not subscribe to PETA and you
must hate them justice all you [ __ ]
they know you should get instead you
should go over to the same a Tuscan
channel because it's did you make this
[ __ ] damage have you been seeing on
my screen when I click on get rid noob I
forgot it was on oh no I can't see your
excrete anymore
it was so easy before why it why is it
so hard now dammit that's right I didn't
want to do this to you can't no no don't
do it
[Music]
you
it's done next one
[Music]
now now please guys 30 seconds kid all
right
do come on baby oh no no I broke though
nothing in there okay let's do a final
one all right all right all right come
on baby you're just gonna lose you
sumbitch you never hug Wow yes no yes I
wasn't actually gonna send anymore yeah
you try to get into my PayPal head you
son of a [ __ ] what is this
hey let me check them D Enzo quick check
get out of my DM g7 perfect no not leave
free
[Music]
send that [ __ ] whoa wait what the [ __ ]
is this you can't stop me I'm in now now
for your favorite of all time where is
it is that it
that's YouTube what the [ __ ] yeah lovely
story [ __ ] yes I can see it too No hey
take it all back
hacked [ __ ] it looks like you win
this round cinnamon toast can the most
dangerous game on the planet know the
pecs
[Music]